[Música]
a empresa abusou de mim e eu permitir
essa frase ouvi de um amigo quando
estava pedindo demissão
dois meses depois de se tornar vice
presidente de uma das maiores empresas
do brasil
ao mesmo tempo muita gente continua aí
sofrendo infeliz adormecida às vezes até
adoecendo mas não tem coragem seja por
sobrevivência
seja por necessidade seja por medo ou
insegurança de tomar o mesmo caminho
o mundo está mudando e essa é a boa
notícia
e eu vi hoje convidar vocês aqui para
participarem desse movimento de
transformação da sociedade
desde que surgiu vem evoluindo passando
por diversos modelos de como a gente se
organiza de como a gente opera de como
as empresas funcionam e de vários
modelos a gente chega no que a gente
está atuando hoje nos últimos 130 anos
desde o surgimento da revolução
industrial
esse movimento é chamado por muitos
autores entre eles o frederico lucas
como o modelo conquistador
o moderno nele a gente deixa de viver
sobre os dogmas e as grandes leis de uma
igreja a gente deixa de viver sobre a
força ea impiedade dos generais ou dos
imperadores ea gente também deixa de
viver com a sensação de que o mundo é
estável e que a gente nasce artesão
morre artesão nasce soldado morre
soldado
a gente passa a viver no mundo que olha
para as máquinas e entende que as
máquinas são complexas mas que podem ser
dominadas
se a gente tiver conhecimento das leis
naturais e também das ciências
assim o conhecimento passa a ter valor e
quem tem conhecimento
consegue crescer consegue crescer na
vida consegue crescer na sociedade
consegue crescer na organização e
alcançar o topo o nosso objetivo passa a
ser se crescer e chegar ao topo quanto
mais a gente crescer melhor a gente vira
acho que uma série de tv the view os
acumuladores compulsivos e já assistiram
esta série é assim que a gente passa a
viver
quanto mais emprego quanto mais
funcionário quanto mais dinheiro quanto
mais carro quanto mais quanto mais
quanto mais e é nesse ambiente gente que
as empresas passam a ser o palco
perfeito para esse abuso que eu comecei
a contar as empresas são só o ambiente é
só uma estrutura mas a gente seres
imperfeitos imaturos do alto da nossa
humanidade do ser humano
passamos a olhar para a empresa que está
lá disponível pra você 24 horas por dia
sete dias por semana 365 dias do ano
aberta esperando você com um convite
para realizar qualquer um dos seus
sonhos
a gente para crescer acumular chegar ao
sucesso usamos esse palco e aí não se
engane
a gente não está sozinho a gente quer
chegar no topo e muita gente que está lá
quer chegar no topo também
e é aí que a gente mergulha de cabeça
nesse abuso e começa a trabalhar e não
para nunca mais eu infelizmente não
consigo mudar as escolhas da minha vida
eu só posso aprender com elas
algumas delas ainda me dói mas por
exemplo eu só tenho fotos da maternidade
com victor que hoje tem 15 anos ou com a
manuela que hoje tem 12 usando roupa
social
eu tava lá entre uma reunião e outra e
quando eu tinha um tempo eu saía
correndo para ir até a maternidade
isso é familiar para alguns de vocês
eu muitas vezes sair de casa com os meus
filhos dormindo e cheguei quando ele já
estava dormindo de novo
isso dói e serve para a gente aprender
que existem outras formas de fazer e
como eu disse para vocês a sociedade que
vem evoluindo começa a entender que esse
mundo conquistador moderno em efeitos
colaterais e que mostram sinais de
esgotamento desse modelo
eu queria trazer dois rápidos efeitos
colaterais
um deles é que a gente causa com esse
modelo uma desigualdade gigante porque
porque se a gente quer chegar no topo
a gente quer como muitos ou como poucos
chegar lá
muitos vão ficar pelo caminho e é por
isso que tem projetos brilhantes
maravilhosos que a gente tem visto hoje
tentando lidar com parte dessa igualdade
que nós mesmos
geramos que eu tô gerando quando eu tô
querendo chegar no topo
eu também tem um grande efeito colateral
de que se o paradigma desse lugar nesse
ambiente é chegar no topo é ter sucesso
eu começo a me perguntar pra que isso
faz sentido
será que vale a pena e esse modelo
conquistador tem uma ausência de sentido
porque não é possível que a gente esteja
aqui nesse mundo só pra isso e é nesse
lugar
olhando para esses efeitos colaterais
que a gente todos nós aqui eu incluso
vamos testando novos modelos estão
tentando enxergar uma outra forma de
viver uma outra forma de se relacionar
com o outro
uma outra forma de habitar nesse mundo
a gente passa a ter um outro elemento
que não está pronto ainda
se vocês me perguntarem tá bom que é
esse novo modelo que é esse novo mundo
ele até já tem nome os mesmos autores
láctea mão o modelo conquistador trazem
esse modelo como modelo evolutivo um
nível de consciência evolutivo legal que
ele não sei ele não está pronto mas ele
está sendo modelado por cada um de nós
no dia a dia cada um de vocês aqui que
estão para repensar
nesse lugar no mundo então trabalhando
para formar esse nível evolutivo e esse
novo viver e de todos os experimentos de
todos os protótipos que eu tenho visto
dessas novas experiências de viver tem
três elementos que estão presentes em
praticamente todos e eu quero dividir
com vocês quais são eles
o primeiro elemento é a gente encontrar
significado e sentido na nossa vida já
virou clichê e às vezes até um pouco mal
interpretado um tal de buscar o
propósito e muitas vezes ele tem sido
mal interpretado porque a gente olha
coisas novas com a nossa mente ainda
poluída com a nossa lente ainda suja e
muitas vezes a pergunta pra pessoas e
até para empresas
qual é o seu propósito ea resposta que
vem é ser rico é ser cada vez mais
reconhecido como o maior da sociedade é
seu melhor do mundo naquela atividade
que eu faço eu não tenho nada contra si
e querer tudo isso eu quero algumas
dessas coisas também faz parte de mim
mas isso não é o sentido eo significado
da vida
isso no máximo é o meu ego dizendo para
vocês o que eu quero construir pra mim
quando eu falo de significado e sentido
eu tô falando daquele negócio que nos
conecta de verdade que nos pega que a
gente consegue entender que tem força
que tem energia que têm paixão e às
vezes é só ensinar às vezes é aprender
às vezes é servir ou a desenvolver seja
ela qual for
a gente nunca vai encontrar isso numa
frase que a gente põe ou na parede o que
a gente carrega para dizer hoje eu tenho
um propósito
a gente vai encontrar ela fazendo a
gente vai encontrá-la quando a gente
sentir que ao fazer aquilo eu sinto
calor
eu sinto energia eu sinto essa borbulha
eu estou sentindo aqui com vocês agora
isso é fluxo isso é sentido e
significado
o segundo elemento que eu queria trazer
para vocês é que a gente precisa ser
inteiro
a gente se conhecer bem a gente hoje tem
cada vez mais alto conhecimento
ferramentas e tudo mas não dá pra gente
ter tudo isso encontrar o sentido eo
significado na nossa vida e sabe fazer o
que trancar na gaveta e jogar a chave
fora não dá
a gente não é só uma parte a gente é um
todo
a gente é toda nossa luz e toda a nossa
sombra ao mesmo tempo nós somos seres
imperfeitos e essa é a beleza
a gente tem que se tornar vulnerável
além de conquistadora ensinou pra gente
que vulnerabilidade é uma fraqueza e que
quando a gente se coloca nesse lugar é
um sinal de derrota mas não é
vulnerabilidade hoje eu não estou
dizendo fraqueza trazendo
vulnerabilidade é hoje a maior
ferramenta pra você se conectar com o
outro para você estabelecer vínculo para
você estabelecer confiança para você
conseguir olhar no outro e enxergar o
que ele tem de inteiro pra você
é assim que a gente está vendo o mundo
hoje inteiro é por isso que as modelos
mostram a sua celulite porque a gente já
não acredita mais nesse mundo idealizado
eu quando vim pro sul morar aqui em
porto alegre assumir a regional sul da
natura e pela primeira vez eu estava
trabalhando numa área comercial e eu
tive que dizer para minha equipe várias
vezes eu não sei qual é a melhor solução
mais juntos
a gente vai encontrar e juntos no ubuntu
a gente chegou a lugares inalcançáveis
sozinhos
o terceiro elemento que eu queria trazer
para vocês de todos esses experimentos é
a crença na abundância quando eu tô
falando da crença da abundância é porque
se eu entendo que o mundo é finito e que
as coisas podem ser escassas já que eu
quero acumular o máximo possível pra mim
vai faltar vai faltar emprego vai faltar
trabalho vai faltar projeto vai faltar
dinheiro
ao contrário eu coloco a minha paixão a
serviço do outro sendo inteiro um
sentido e significado na minha vida eu
posso acreditar e eu não estou falando
que crê em que algo é
vai nos acontecer não eu acredito que
através dessa conexão abundância vai nos
servir tudo o que a gente precisa virar
na hora certa na quantidade certa do
jeito certo
eu trabalho para fazer acontecer
conectado com essa paixão e aí seja
limpando o chão seja cozinhando seja
palestrando seja advogando seja fazendo
aquilo que de verdade nos conecta eu
tenho certeza não vai faltar é acreditar
nessa abundância
eu então contei pra vocês um pouco
desses três elementos que têm
participado mais ou menos de todos os
ensaios que a gente tem visto sobre esse
novo modelo evolutivo
a gente tem sentido e significado
naquilo que faz sem inteiro e crê na
abundância
eu tenho experimentado isso na minha
vida
alguns anos eu fui mordido pelo mosquito
da inquietação existencial e desde então
eu venho experimentando viver de uma
forma diferente
acho que como muitos de vocês que estão
aqui nesse movimento
eu confesso para vocês que eu ainda
tenho que fazer esses experimentos de
alguma forma meio-campo flamengo para
poder conversar com esses conquistadores
que estão por aí
ainda olhando com uma perspectiva mais
evolutiva
eu por exemplo nessas minhas camuflagens
vendo um projeto de planejamento
estratégico numa empresa e ao trabalhar
com eles
dois meses depois consigo levar um dos
sócios para a terapia e eu tenho certeza
que eu vou dar muito mais resultado
nessa empresa com esse sócio trabalhando
a sua terapia do que ajudando na
estratégia da empresa
da mesma forma que hoje sendo inteiro eu
quando vou buscar a linha na escola que
está aqui hoje com 4 anos de idade e que
como eu posso fazer novas escolhas
através do futuro e não do passado com
ali eu tenho escolhido viver diferente
eu consigo ir buscar a lia e comer
pipoca andando pelo quarteirão
como a gente faz muitos dias e tem sido
cada vez mais comum
mas eu ainda tenho que dizer para as
outras pessoas
outro compromisso me chama eu ainda no
meio que é o dia da minha pipoca com ali
não posso fazer isso ainda
eu não sei mais qual é a minha profissão
eu não sei exatamente o que eu tenho
trabalhado
eu sei que quando tem um chamado de algo
que me interessa e que a recíproca é
verdadeira
e essa vulnerabilidade dos dois lados se
mostra eu tô lá engajado para fazer o
que tiver que fazer
felizmente até hoje não tem faltado
eu estou trabalhando nesses experimentos
uma das coisas mais curiosas que tenha
por exemplo quando eu vou para a
recepção das empresas eu chego na
recepção e falou eu sou daniel levy em
conversar com a renata
após não o senhor é da onde eu não sou
de nenhum lugar sou eu o daniel levy
e aí eu escuto no interfone
é o senhor daniel levy particular para a
senhora renata eu saio de lá andando e
sentindo um detetive secreto com todo
mundo me olhando e falando a onde o que
ele vai falar com a renata é assim que
eu me sinto hoje nesse mundo camuflado
de evolutivo para lidar com os
conquistadores que ainda estão por aí
acho que muitos de vocês também estão
juntos nesse movimento também estão
fazendo seus próprios experimentos e a
boa notícia é que cada vez são mais
pessoas nelas
esse convite está cada vez mais grosso
cada vez mais a gente tá lá vivendo de
forma inteira através da nossa essência
e acreditando na beleza e na abundância
da vida do viver e do porque a gente
quer viver
se eu tiver só uma forma uma frase pra
falar pra vocês uma dica pra dar pra
vocês aqui
depois disso que eu falei eu queria
dizer pra vocês que vocês precisam fazer
só uma coisa para se ajudarem de verdade
nesse movimento de transformação
eu diria para vocês que vocês têm que
ser cada dia e todo dia na vida de vocês
vocês buscarem ser cada vez mais cada
vez mais só gente obrigado
[Aplausos]